hace semanas estaban desplegadas a las
puertas del país las tropas rusas las
cruzaron este martes antes del amanecer
en estas imágenes proporcionadas por los
guardias fronterizos ucranianos tanques
rusos entrando en ucrania por el sur a
través de crimea ocupada desde 2014 por
rusia una invasión por tierra pero
también por mar a través de los puertos
de odessa y mariupol donde han
desembarcado refuerzos de soldados de
moscú las tropas rusas también entraron
por el este a través de las regiones de
hardcore la segunda ciudad más grande de
ucrania y a través de la región de
lugansk en tumbas las tropas rompieron
la primera línea de defensa de las
fuerzas ucranianas muy bien equipadas y
organizadas en varios estratos
las tropas de la república popular de
dones han avanzado 3 kilómetros hacia
volvió bajo
la frontera norte tampoco ha sido
salvada con tanques cruzando el puesto
fronterizo de 100 kiska vehículos
blindados llegaron en particular por
belarús cuyo presidente lukashenko es un
aliado difícil
lukashenko y su régimen comparten toda
la responsabilidad computing por esta
guerra innecesaria gusta la importación
ilegítima de tropas extranjeras
convierte a belarús en una parte
importante en este conflicto armado
me dirijo a los ucranianos nos
avergüenza el papel que ha desempeñado
el territorio de nuestro país en esta
guerra el presidente bielorruso asegura
que sus tropas no están implicadas en la
invasión de ucrania sin negar que
ayudaron a los tanques rusos a entrar
por su territorio según el gobierno
ucraniano las fuerzas terrestres rusas
entraron en la región de quiebra a
través de bielorrusia para atacar
objetos militares